was passiert wenn ein asteroid auf die
erde zurast was sind die konsequenzen
eines einschlags jedes jahr schlagen
zahlreiche asteroiden auf der erde ein
meistens in menschenleeren gegenden
das risiko ist also groß dass ein
einschlag wie in china bis 2013 auch mal
nicht in der atmosphäre explodiert
sondern eine millionenstadt trifft doch
der einschlag im meer ist der
wahrscheinlichste das los alamos
national laboratory hat zu diesen
szenarien intensiv geforscht und eine
erschreckende erkenntnis gewonnen tricks
und science fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende wissenschafts videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann und nur
dann verpasst er nichts los geht's auf
sky tickets startet gerade eine
spektakuläre serie 8 tage
darin sind noch acht tage zeit bis ein
riesiger hast du ihn auf europa stürzen
wird und der kontinent zerstört wird
schon bevor der asteroid einschlägt
bricht das absolute chaos aus und die
menschen zeigen sich von ihrer
schlechtesten seite denn auch das ist
die konsequenz eines von drohnen
einschlags die zivile ordnung bricht
auseinander ein absolut realistisches
szenario
man muss sich ja nur mal selber fragen
was man tun würde wenn er recht und
ordnung außer kraft gesetzt werden aber
was tut eigentlich beim einschlag eines
großen zu ihnen mit einem durchmesser
von mehreren hundert metern die wirklich
großen brocken mit durchmessern von
mehreren kilometern die haben wir einen
blick und in den nächsten 100 jahren
wird keiner auf die erde stürzen aber
tatsächlich schlagen ja jedes jahr rund
zwei größere asteroiden in
menschenleeren gegenden ein ohne dass
wir es merken darüber haben wir ja öfter
berichtet das risiko eines größeren
einschlags auch in bewohnten gebieten
ist also de facto da und die
konsequenzen reichen bis zur zerstörung
ganzer millionenstädte die nasa bereitet
sich mit ihren zahlreichen missionen zu
asteroiden darauf vor einen solchen
anschlag zu verhindern zahlreiche
strategien dazu werden durchdacht und
sollen in zukunft auch getestet werden
das los alamos national laboratories hat
zum möglichen einschlägen geforscht und
ist zu verblüffenden wenn nicht
erschreckenden erkenntnissen gekommen
70 prozent der erde sind mit wasser
bedeckt wird dass ein einschlag dort am
wahrscheinlichsten ist einen solchen
einschlag hat das forschungsteam
durchgerechnet
und ist ebenso eine erschreckenden
erkenntnis gelangt denn ganz anders als
vorhergesagt sind hunderte meter hohe
zunahme ist gar nicht die schlimmste
folge bzw
da gibt es sogar eine entwarnung da der
einschlag punktförmig ist verlieren
diese wellen ihre energie sehr schnell
und sind ab einer entfernung des
einschlags vom festland von mehr als 20
kilometern mit aller wahrscheinlichkeit
nach gar nicht mehr gefährlich etwas
ganz anderes könnte die furchtbare
konsequent sein
mehrere hundert megatonnen wasser werden
durch den einschlag bis in die
stratosphäre katapultiert ein teil davon
sehr schnell über den eintritt weg des
asteroiden weil er hier ein teil vakuum
zurückgelassen hat das jetzt das wasser
ansaugt in der stratosphäre kann das
wasser dann monate oder jahre verbleiben
und heizt dann den treibhauseffekt auf
der erde weiter an
das wäre die schlimmste katastrophe und
könnte zu millionen toten führen sprich
ein einschlag direkt in eine
millionenstadt während zwar verheerend
und würde sie wahrscheinlich wie eine
atombombe vernichten ein einschlag in
einen ozean aber könnte weitaus
verheerender sein weil er auswirkungen
auf die ganze erde haben würde
und jetzt geht es weiter mit der endzeit
serie acht tage dafür hier draufklicken
und erspart damit 50 eiskalt ticket
stream mit dem entertainment bis ende
april
neben den highlights acht tage the
walking dead und game of thrones auch
tausende weitere serien highlights damit
könnt ihr bis ende april serien genießen
und den märz ab jetzt bekommt er
zusätzlich nach oben drauf bis dann
bleibt dran